i don't want life to beat me i've seen
life beat so many people most people
around me life beat them when you ask
them what happened what do most people
say life happened man i had it there and
this happened in that
i don't want life to beat
me we republished this tweet from the
numbers game on our channel page and it
says squid game creator wrote the show
in 2009 but was rejected by studios for
10 years he once had to stop writing the
script and sell his 675 dollar laptop
due to money troubles and today squid
game is number one i guess in 90
countries and is set to become the most
watched show in netflix
history
what is your reaction to this the story
this chain of events
i mean
if it's true it's awesome
um i i
it's it's that
feeling of of the never say die attitude
no matter how much rejection you get you
still keep plowing forward and i love
those stories i do
um
i think that
i always
if the story is is
completely third party then i i feel
that it's it's an awesome story of
perseverance
but if it's a
a netflix story which i i i'm a netflix
subscriber i i definitely watch it but
they can tell you
what's number one and you just have to
believe that it's true we have no way of
verifying that it's number one
only that they said it was number one
i always wonder that whenever i'm
looking at the
the like this is number one for the week
and number ten for the week i'm like how
do we really know that that's number one
and number ten
it's just because we went there and they
told us that it was so
um but like i said before if it's the
story if the story is true and it's you
know it's a third party story that's a
great story of perseverance um i think
that we
people are born with a lot of quit in
them for some reason or maybe it's
developed over the years
but when they start to reach those
obstacles or any kind of adversity it's
it's very easy to to give up
and
unfortunately i think that we all have
people in our lives who care about us
greatly they care about us deeply and
they will see us going through some
adversity and it's like oh man it's been
years you probably should maybe maybe
you should start thinking about
something else because they care about
you and they want you to be successful
and they don't want to see you kind of
beating your head against the wall and
they'll sometimes advise you to
maybe maybe throw in a towel on this one
and i'm pretty sure he had that person
next to him telling him that
and when i always hear about people who
have those
advisors with them i always say find new
advisors
because
the only thing that
people should help you understand is why
you care so deeply about what you're
doing
that's always the real question why do
you care so deeply and after that they
should just be trying to help you
achieve whatever the goal is you're
trying to achieve
or give you the best advice they could
on how to achieve it you know
i know you said you left your uh job as
a marketing coordinator at a nursing
skilled nursing facility
but have you ever been tempted to give
up on films as
many
rollercoaster rides as you've been on it
sounds like
no
no i i've i've had times where it was
tough and
ultimately you had to feed the safe you
know you have to say okay you know i
gotta focus on putting money over here
and this and that but
i've
i
they always say that the the line
between
uh self-belief and delusion is very thin
and i must be riding that line because
i've just i've always believed
especially after i left the skilled
nursing facility that it's this robust
is this robust and
i'm very very fortunate that i've gotten
to a point where now i self-finance all
of my projects
and
you know i
i think that
i can service two
different demographics i can service the
horror crowd which is what most people
know my work uh from is horror and in
that like 80s style horror
and then i can also serve a niche of
people who are like me who like the kind
of stuff that i like and that's a
smaller niche but i can still serve that
niche and that's where i get to
really be the most creative that i could
possibly be
but
that took time to get to that point and
it took a lot of sacrifice to get to
that point
and
i think
there are moments in everybody's life
where they realize that
man this is very difficult and i wonder
if the juice is worth the squeeze at
this point
but it is my belief that
once you start to feel that
that's when you should be your most
um
decisive in going forward
and the reason is because
success and everything you're looking
for is just on the other side of that
it's it's when you don't have the teeth
to keep going and you give up you you
cut yourself short and you always wonder
what if i just kept going what if i had
just
given it another this or made that one
extra phone call but i never want those
questions and what i found is right when
you have when you get past that point
everything i was looking for was just on
the other side
it was just on the other side and i'm
starting to reap a lot of the benefits
of that perseverance and continuously
going forward
would you say that's one of your biggest
fears is the fear of regret you don't
ever want to get to a certain point and
go i wish i had just done this tried
harder
um
no i i think more than anything i just
i don't want to feel like and it's going
to sound really weird but i don't want
to feel like life beat me
i don't want life to beat me i've seen
life beat so many people most people
around me life beat them when you ask
them what happened what do most people
say life happened man i had it there and
this happened in that
i don't want life to beat me i take
everything that comes with life
and i try to use it to my benefit
everything you know at this point my
wife is is is pregnant right
guess who's gonna be in my movie is it
my kid
he's gonna be the star of the movie you
take everything that's coming to you and
you use it
whatever happens in my life i use it if
it's if it's something crazy and wild
happen it's a story in the script if
this happened in that it's in the script
i'm taking everything that comes it
comes towards me and i'm using it i'm
using it as fuel i'm using it as
something to keep moving forward
life won't beat me
it won't
we're hoping to get your reaction to
this comment and that is this is not a
triumph it's a tragedy and it's a sign
of just how much the industry needs to
do better because creative original work
should not be just a long struggle to
put it out
referring to the squid game
and
what are your thoughts on that
um
he didn't let life beat him
no he didn't let life beat him but to
say it's not a triumph it's a tragedy
it's like wow really
i i don't i
look
you
everything that we do especially in this
industry everything you're trying to do
is met
with resistance and opposition it just
is
it is if
the way i try to explain it to certain
people when they say oh it's nepotism
and this person and that and this is why
i can't get in and
okay
let's say you are trying to to get
through the door
okay
in every film i've worked with
let's say we take the collective of
everybody i've worked with in that film
maybe seven percent of them are people i
actually work with again
maybe
okay
and it all has to do with the way i run
my set
and what i expect from people
in the end not everybody is gonna
operate at that same level okay
and while i can be very chill i can also
be pretty intense you know
now because i'm very passionate about
what i'm doing
so
if that's the case
after a certain amount of time i'm
hopeful
that the percentage of people that i'm
working with
is growing
so that now i'm carrying over most
people from one project to the next why
am i doing that because these are the
people that i know these are the people
that i trust
okay and i want to keep them next to me
and i want to keep them working with me
so when the next person comes along and
they say well guess what i can do this
and i can do that
i say you probably could
and you're probably great at it
but then i would have to take a chance
and maybe on this project i'm already
taking these chances i can't afford to
take that chance
and that person can see that as
an obstacle to their growth into their
success because they couldn't get that
position on that film they couldn't get
that thing out there and if they go to
more and more people like me who begin
to accumulate a nice team that they work
with a very a team that makes everything
work smoothly
they're going to meet that same
opposition
right
and it will become
a game in terms of trying to find that
crack
to squeeze in to get whatever it is that
you're trying to to get made made
so
when people speak of the struggle to get
things done that's really the struggle
the struggle is
first of all he's written something
right
and
he has to get it in front of someone to
read it well guess what
there's
hundreds and thousands of other scripts
that are trying to be read
everybody's trying to get their stuff
made
the key is going to be the perseverance
and to keep going and that to me is the
triumph of the story as i said if it's
if it's the true story and it's
you know a third party and they're
talking about it
to me that is a triumph that's not a
tragedy it's a triumph
you took something that is not a very
um
it's not a cheap story to make like he
can't go out and get a a
camera phone and shoot that like it
doesn't work the same he's going to need
a serious budget guess what that's even
more competitive because to get people
to spend the
millions of dollars it's going to take
to make that and market that
that's tough
it's very competitive
and it shouldn't be easy because if it
were easy it wouldn't be worth it
so
excuse me sorry um i i disagree with
that it's it's not a it's not a tragedy
it's a triumph
what was behind door number one what we
didn't tell you what was missing from
that tweet
um is that director huang did not stop
during those 10 years he kept working
and he wrote and directed i guess three
projects
during that time and a lot of people
um they may have just been stuck on that
first one
and and trying to make that one happen
so
he
for whatever reason kept going and made
other work and
i i don't know the exact story of how it
happened but um
it sounds like he wasn't going to let
life beat him down either so yeah it's a
story of perseverance like i said he he
may feel that it was a tragedy he may
because you know
two people looking at the same event can
see two totally different things right
to me that's not a that's not a tragedy
to me that's a triumph and hearing that
he made other projects while he was
trying to get that one made even further
you know uh solidifies that it's it's
perseverance at its best
and it's never giving up and
his plan a i don't think was just to
make squid game his plan a was to to be
successful and get something made and
that's exactly what he was getting done
squid game just took a little bit longer
than the others but
ultimately he got that one done as well
when you were
on your way out from the nursing home
did people try to talk you out of
leaving
yes yeah
but
i always make sure that i seek first to
understand and then to be understood
and
i could understand why they didn't want
me to go because you know i was a
salesman and i was pretty you know
decent at what i did so
they didn't want me to leave
because then that meant that they would
have to find another salesperson and
then they'd have to take a gamble you
know and see if that person will work
out and and when it comes to
the healthcare industry especially when
it's end of life and it's it's uh you
know assistant living facilities at
skilled nursing facilities home health
and hospice
is super competitive
it's super competitive so you need very
aggressive sales people and that was
ultimately why they didn't want me to go
i mean i think there were a couple
people who just like talking to me every
day
and those people didn't want me to go
and i think a few of the patients but i
think or residents i should say but um
for the most part it was it was because
of
my skills that they didn't want me to
leave and
once i understood that i said that's
even more of a reason to to to kind of
leave and not feel too bad about it you
know
well they try to talk jeff bezos out of
making amazon so well there you go
you